Я приїхала робити дослідження про українських мігрантів
до Австралії пострадянської хвилі.
Існує декілька класифікацій хвиль міграції.
І перша хвиля була в 1917-18 роках.
Не дуже велика кількість літератури є про це,
але є кілька досліджень, які висвітлюють,
ким є люди з першої хвилі.
Більшість літератури пише про другу хвилю.
Це були... Їх називають більше «політичними мігрантами».
Це ті українці, які після Другої світової війни
опинилися в Австрії чи інших європейських місцях.
І їм запропонували повертатися до Радянського Союзу.
На той момент вони сказали, що вони не хочуть
і будуть шукати інші місця для проживання.
І тоді Канада, і США, і, я думаю, що було ще декілька країн
(і Австралія була одним з таких варіантів),
які запрошували всіх,
хто хотів переїхати з Європи на той момент.
Це були [англійською] переселенці, переміщені особи,
[що хотіли] поїхати до Австралії.
Це друга хвиля,
дуже багато про неї написано.
І тут, до речі, кістяк всієї української міграції
в Австралії, Канаді та США,
він був сформований після Другої світової війни
міграціями в ці країни.
Потім була третя хвиля в 1970-х роках.
Не дуже багато написано про це,
але було підвищення рівня міграції
до Австралії з України та інших республік.
Також з Радянського Союзу
та інших країн-друзів Радянського Союзу.
І ось остання хвиля, яка пов'язана з розпадом
Радянського Союзу, з 1991 роком і [англійською] далі,
яку я досліджувала.
[англійською] Як у вас справи?
[англійською] У мене все добре, дякую.
А як у вас справи?
[англійською] Ми вже можемо обійматись, але обережно.
[англійською] А це мій малюк.
— [англійською] Справді?
— [англійською] Справді!
— [англійською] Можна поглянути?
— [англійською] Звісно-звісно!
— [англійською] І скільки їй місяців?
— [англійською] Два з половиною.
— [англійською] Вона у вас чудова!
— [англійською] Так, і висока.
— [англійською] І справді.
— [англійською] Так, вона височенька.
[англійською] Це, до речі, моя мама.
[англійською] Справді! Рада знайомству.
[англійською] Як потрапити в будівлю?
[англійською] З корпусу 1,
але при вході потрібно провести карткою.
[англійською] Але з вашою карткою я
не можу зайти у корпус 10, правильно?
[англійською] Ні, оскільки корпус 10 зачинений.
Відкриті лише корпуси 1, 2 та 11.
[англійською] То як мені зайти в корпус 9?
Я там призначила зустріч.
[англійською] Можливо, вам підійде бібліотека для цього?
У бібліотеці багато простору.
[англійською] Можливо й так.
А не підкажете, де вона? Я не мала нагоди перевірити.
[англійською] Бібліотека знаходиться вище на поверсі.
Ми зараз в [англійською] Центральному парку.
Це такий сквер, я б сказала,
де люди відпочивають.
І ці будинки є [англійською] житловими.
Тобто тут проживають люди.
Також тут є [англійською] торгівельний центр,
де люди можуть купити усілякі продукти.
А ось і мій університет.
Тобто воно все поруч, що досить зручно.
А ось тут дуже класна кава, до речі.
Узагалі в Австралії дуже класна кава.
[англійською] Я надзвичайно відома!
[сміється]
[англійською] За це потрібно платити!
[англійською] Ваше лате з собою.
[англійською] Ви чудова, просто чудова!
[сміється]
[англійською] Так, вагітні жінки особливо вродливі.
[англійською] О, ви вагітна. Це чудово!
[англійською] Я не так давно народила дитину.
Тому я вас розумію.
[англійською] Справді?
У вас дівчинка чи хлопчик?
— [англійською] Дівчинка.
— [англійською] А ви знаєте, хто у вас буде?
[англійською] Ні, не знаю.
Це дитина-сюрприз.
[англійською] Побачимо, хто це буде.
Я приїхала 2012 року,
і коли мене запитували, звідки я,
наприклад [англійською] водій таксі,
то про Україну мало хто знав.
Після того, як у нас відбулася Революція,
а Україна була по всіх новинах,
то про неї стало більше відомо.
Тоді стали більше дивитися і впізнавати,
і ми могли навіть вести [англійською] розмови
з багатьма людьми про Україну.
Це було доволі цікаво.
[англійською] О, дуже вам дякую!
Супер! Я вже домовилася,
що ми будемо в [англійською] бібліотеці.
Ми підемо в нову [англійською] будівлю.
Добре-добре, дякую! До зустрічі, Юрко.
[англійською] До побачення!
Я просто пішла на вебсайт
і знайшла професора соціології.
І написала, що я — українка,
мене звуть Оля.
Хочу вивчати міграцію українців до Австралії.
Я знаю, що це дуже велика
[англійською] прогалина в дослідженнях,
оскільки не було ніяких книг,
ніяких статей з цього питання.
А якщо і були, то ці дослідження
були дуже фрагментарними,
сфокусованими, переважно,
на другій хвилі міграції, поствоєнній.
Про те, хто є новими мігрантами,
хто ці молоді люди,
які приїжджають зараз, після розпаду
Радянського Союзу  і створення незалежної України,
не було зовсім ніякої інформації.
І от що відбувається з 1991 року:
дуже багато людей сюди приїжджає
по [англійською] професійних програмах міграції.
Тобто маючи [англійською] навички
в необхідних в Австралії професіях,
вони сюди приїжджають.
Моє дослідження показало, що ті українці,
які приїжджали сюди до 2004 року,
приїжджали і залишались тут
по [англійською] програмах об'єднання сімей.
Вони приїжджали сюди до батьків
і залишалися тут.
І з 2004 року рівень міграції по
[англійською] професійних програмах
перевищив рівень міграції по програмах
з [англійською] об'єднання сімей
та програмах міграції для [англійською] біженців.
Тобто це означає, що якість українських мігрантів,
які переїжджають в Австралію, також зросла.
З 2004 року.
Хто це? Це переважно ІТ, інженери, різні професії є.
Але, переважно, це були технічні спеціальності,
яких потребує Австралія.
Ось, наприклад, минулого року
ми їздили в Оксфордський університет.
У нас там були [англійською] майстеркласи,
ми зібрали десять академіків,
які є [англійською] членами
Української Демократичної Ініціативи.
І ми робили з ними проєкт
про діаспору та демократію,
як діаспора впливає на те,
що відбувається в сучасній Україні.
І ми написали книжку про це,
яка називається
[англійською] «Демократія, Діаспора, Територія».
Пам'ятаєте, ви давали мені виконувати
[англійською] додаткові дослідження?
Дуже давно, ще коли я приїхала,
щоб зібрати інтерв'ю.
І от вийшла книжка, зайняло так багато часу,
бо цей процес [англійською] триває вічність.
І тут є про Фусу, тут Юсефей написав
[англійською] рецензію, все тут є.
Я дуже дякую за підтримку, тому що без вас
цей процес був би не такий швидкий, я думаю,
не такий повний і, ймовірно, я б зібрала
значно менше інтерв'ю, ніж тут написано.
Тобто ми робимо такі проєкти
з [англійською] членами нашої спілки,
які сидять у будь-яких університетах світу,
цікавляться та роблять дослідження про Україну.
Тут навіть ми створюємо робочі місця,
тобто це наша компанія,
яка має свій продукт.
І цей продукт є платформою для брендів,
лідерів думок та агентств,
які можуть використовувати нашу платформу
для аналітики соціальних медіа та [англійською] швидких покупок,
продажу в соціальних мережах.
Ті, хто знайомий тут з українцями,
це переважно досвідчені люди, фахівці.
Я завжди пишаюся тим, що я — українка.